cela fait bientôt un an que la longue
dame brune nous a quittés sans que
l'émotion causée par ce départ se soit
estompé comme que d'ici là son oeuvre
chanter elle nous a légué ses mémoires
interrompu qui paraissent chez fayard
sous le titre s'il était un piano noir
et qui passionnerait ses fidèles il
n'est pas difficile
allez lire d'imaginer leurs auteurs
revenue chez elle apprécie après le
spectacle et prenant la plume pour
esquisser ses souvenirs
laissez-moi vous lire tout simplement ce
qu'elle écrit à l'orée de son livre le
27 avril 1997
plus jamais je ne rentrerai sur scène je
ne chanterai jamais plus plus jamais ces
heures passées dans la loge a souligné
l'oeil et à dessiner les lèvres avec
toute cette scintille ans de poudre et
de lumière en s'obligeant avec le
pinceau à la lenteur la lenteur de se
faire belle pour vous plus jamais
revêtir le strass le pailleté du velours
noir plus jamais cette attente dans les
coulisses le coeur à se rompre
plus jamais le rideau qui s'ouvre plus
jamais le pied posé dans la lumière sur
la note de cymbales éclaté
barbara fut une enfant pauvre élevée
avant guerre à marseille puis à roanne
est adoré par une grand-mère venue de
moldavie
elle en parle admirablement tout
frémissant encore de souvenirs pour
toute une vie
les beignets aux fruits l'odeur de la
poudre de riz les débuts sur scène comme
girls dans violettes impériales les
grandes admirations marianne oswald
denise glaser gérard depardieu et puis
le retour du père à nantes
un beau jour de 1959 comme dans la
chanson dans sa chanson surnom
je me souviens on